So, personality psychologists do in fact use the kinds of measures that Lauren
and Susan just discussed to do many different things. In fact, it's the job of
the personality psychologist to assess personality. And if they're researchers,
they do this either quantitatively or qualitatively. And quantitative
personality assessment involves behavior observations or self reports.
Qualitative assessment of personality involves interviews or projective test.
So, researchers of personality might then look at how personality is associated
with or related to outcomes like health, or career interest, our creativity, or
marital satisfaction. Now clinical psychologists, who study personality, may
use personality assessment to diagnose personality disorders, and come up with
a treatment plan to help them. Now let's talk about where personality comes
from.